Now, you’ve heard of blacks holes, but what
about 5 dimensional black holes?!
Now, we experience the world in 3 dimensions
plus time - that makes 4.
To prove the existence of any other dimensions
we would have to use high powered experiments
like the Large Hadron Collider or theoretical
physics.
For instance, string theory, which suggests
that the most elementary particles in the
universe are tiny vibrating strings.
This theory proposes that the universe could
be made up of as many as 11 dimensions.
Weird, right?
Now for theoretical physicists this opened
up a world of possibilities.
For instance, back in 2002, physicists theorized
that if the universe did have 5 dimensions,
-- a crazy kind of 5D black hole, called a
black ring, could exist.
However, it wasn’t until recently that they
were able to model what these would look like.
It was scientists from UNiversity of Cambridge
and Queen Mary University of London who used
the COSMOS supercomputer to run a simulation
on black rings.
The results published in the journal Physical
Review Letters found that a black ring is
highly unstable.
And that its structure can pull apart, kind
of like silly putty.
The researchers found that a black ring could
in fact, be stretched out so thinly, that
it could produce smaller mini-black holes
that were pinched off from the main ring.
Now as the ring breaks apart it becomes what’s
called a “naked singularity”, which is
where things gets weird.
Now a singularity is located right in the
center of a black hole and it’s where the
gravitational field is most dense.
But since nothing, not even light can escape
a black hole, we can’t see these singularities.
But a black ring in a 5 dimensional universe
with a naked singularity would be very different.
Naked singularities are so named, because
they are no longer hidden within the boundaries
of a black hole or the event horizon.
Remember, these singularities are formed as
a black ring is breaking apart to form new
black holes.
Basically, what this all means is that we
could potentially see them!* And unlike a
4D singularity, you might even be able to
GO INSIDE OF A NAKED SINGULARITY AND COME
OUT ALIVE.
Simply put, all this turns Einstein’s theory
of relativity on it’s head.
That’s because all of Einstein’s equations
to predict the future of our universe and
how it works are all based on the idea that
it exists in 4 dimensions.
If we can prove that black rings exist it
means that his theory, isn’t wrong but could
be incomplete.
This means that researchers would have to
find a whole new theory to explain the universe.
But like I said, this is only a computer model,
for now it’s like scientists are just having
fun seeing how far they can stretch physics
on a computer.
TT Newsletter push
And if you want to keep updated on all things
science, be sure to check out TestTube’s
newsletter!
Get a weekly round-up of our most popular
videos across all our shows at TestTube.com/fwd
The physics of black holes is strange and
weird.
I mean nothing can escape them!
How is that even possible, can nothing really
escape a black hole?
Well Julian has the answer, right here.